se ha conocido que las versiones
iniciales de los los fiscales que acusan
a
stewards líder de la milicias y cuatro
integrantes más de este grupo pues son
acusados ya formalmente en este juicio
que inició hoy de Conspiración
silenciosa Es decir de tratar de evitar
la transferencia del poder el 6 de enero
se dicen que hay dicen los que los
fiscales que acusan a estos integrantes
de la milicia que tienen pruebas
suficientes que demuestran Cómo durante
semanas antes del 6 de enero esto estos
integrantes se reunieron en Virginia en
Arlington y reunieron a muchos
integrantes más armados para tomar
acciones militares ese día sin embargo
los abogados de las de los milicianos
inculpados dicen que no son culpables es
decir no aceptan los cargos argumentando
que estos milicianos estaban esperando
una orden el presidente del ex
presidente Donald Trump de decretar acta
de insurrección y que entonces bajo esta
acta de insurrección estos milicianos
habrían podido actuar de forma privada
usando estrategia militar precisamente
para que Donald Trump se quedase en el
poder lo que dicen juristas expertos
sobre el tema es que está argumento de a
estar esperando el acta de insurrección
por parte de un presidente no habilita
un grupo tercero un grupo militar
privado de tomar la justicia por las
manos o de actuar de forma privada
militarmente y además hay muchas pruebas
de espías sobre todo que indican que
pues en conversaciones después del 6 de
enero este estuvo habría dicho que si
hubiera tenido rifles si hubiera tomado
el Capitolio
Cristóbal Seguiremos muy de cerca este
proceso pero abordemos ahora otra
noticia judicial del día en Estados
Unidos y es que empezó el nuevo periodo
de sesiones de la corte Suprema Cuáles
son los temas en la agenda de este nuevo
año judicial
pues un día histórico hoy en Estados
Unidos en Washington porque la primera
mujer afroamericana Pues en hace parte
de los nuevos integrantes de los nueve
magistrados de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia sin embargo hace parte de una
minoría liberal apenas tres magistrados
son de corte liberal versus los seis de
corte conservador que recientemente
formaron esta mayoría y entonces pues
ese ese ese input que va a tener que
tangible en este grupo de liberales va a
ser muy poco significativo y muy poco
significativo en cuatro temas
principales primero en Pues el alcance
que va a tener la agencia de protección
ambiental en cuanto a las aguas que no
están en terreno Federal en otro tema
importante será el tema de los derechos
de los votantes y de las leyes
electorales para las minorías también
está el tema de los Derechos LG LG de
los derechos de homosexuales se ve el
lgtbi también y también el tema de la
acción afirmativa serán cuatro temas muy
importantes que se tratarán en este
nueva sesión de la Corte Suprema acá en
Estados Unidos que va desde hoy hasta
enero